what was the bit supposed to be when you
[ __ ] your pants the what do you call it
dirty dancing where uh it was meant to
be where i would go and jump off of a
crate and platform yeah and we man was
to hold me up like dancing style that
was the whole bit that's yeah that's all
not the other way around huh
and then like you know that was the
third part of the movie the third take
my stomach's really started hurting oh
wait third take well yeah because of me
smashing him not not the third take of
me pooping the third take of me jumping
on him you're trying to get it just
right because and said that didn't make
the cut it just wasn't it was it wasn't
worth it you know right but the [ __ ]
and he was he was hating and he was that
he was he was the happiest person in the
world that i [ __ ] so he didn't have to
keep getting smashed he was so happy
with that yeah he could he was just
ecstatic yeah yeah we went for it
you know
i mean i guess like you guys had like a
bunch of bits that were pretty brutal
you and we man
they were all in a couple of days yeah
they filmed them all at the same time
the uh
what do you call the pendulum thing the
wii smash is what i've called but i
don't know what it's called is that when
that's with him and zach jumped at the
same time that was a triple wedgie yeah
that was pretty gnarly no we all three
got banged up on that smash thing they
just said it was too close to the
triple wedgie which is just so oh so you
didn't use the the wii smash it's uh
there's a bunch coming out in 4.5 yeah
4.5 is loaded okay i wonder why 4.5 when
paramount has uh
paramount plus
their own streaming thing they
sold 4.5 to netflix
for money i mean i'm sure they they
didn't they didn't hurt themselves sure
yeah maybe it's on like a time they only
have it for so long and it'll default to
paramount plus i assure you that
paramount's like why they got the best
of us yeah
so
so will jackass forever go to netflix as
well no
paramount plus has
first rights on forever
okay it'll go to paramount plus first
and then be able to rent on other
streaming sites
and then they're saying in 2024 a
paramount is going 100 percent streaming
their stuff only like they won't let you
go anywhere else so i don't know how
that affects the future
yeah
america if you thought jackass forever
was crazy oh boy do i have a show for
you it's a multimedia comedy show called
the bucket list tour and the stuff i
filmed for this show is way too hot for
jackass like the general anesthesia bike
ride the vasectomy olympics and
sky jacking the footage is so intense we
have full grown men passing out at
almost every city this bus goes to
so if you think you can handle it get
your tickets right now at stevo.com
[Applause]